[Music]
thanks for joining us today we're
launching unreal engine 5.0 to all
developers among game developers 48 of
announced next generation console titles
are powered by unreal automotive
designers fashion designers and
architects are doing everything from
design visualization to brand
activations and entertainment crossovers
next up i'd like to introduce kim le
berry cto of epic games hello everybody
for us to really be sure that unreal
engine 5 has achieved the goals we set
for it to really change the way
interactive and linear media is made
we needed to push the engine to a new
extreme unreal engine 5 isn't just about
making existing ways of doing things
faster it's about finding whole new
approaches to transform the way content
is made and experienced
micro polygon geometry allows for
billions of triangles on the screen at
any moment and luma's real-time global
illumination enables highly realistic
lighting they combine together to
generate real-time content at a level
that would have seemed like magic only a
few years ago developer efficiency is a
recurring theme that goes beyond unreal
engine and into our other products
meta human creator and quicksome maker
scans show how we're enabling creators
to make very high quality content more
quickly than ever before unreal engine 5
is the foundation of next-gen content
creation so what are you waiting for go
make something amazing starting today
it's never been easier to bring your
creative vision to life we redesigned
the unreal editor ui making it easier to
use with a streamlined modern look
keeping you inside the 3d world that
you're building and we built tools for
animation and modeling directly into the
editor enabling developers to fine tune
and iterate on content in context
without round trips to external packages
lumen frees developers to create dynamic
worlds with high quality global
illumination
nanite relieves developers from worrying
about draw call polygon and memory
budgets from a geometry perspective
and our new open world tools allow
developers to collaborate in a single
massive level and to get you building
even faster alongside ue5 we're shipping
lyra a new starter game it's a complete
end-to-end networked multiplayer game
project that is an excellent foundation
to build a game upon without having to
start from a blank slate
it's built for modular components
utilizes epic online services for
matchmaking and is designed to run on pc
console and mobile with lyra you can
jump in customize it add new content and
begin play testing from day one to see
how easy it is to build on top of lyra
let's jump in the editor with zach
parrish this level is lit primarily with
just the sunlight as a matter of fact if
i move the sun around
you can see how lumen just takes that
light and naturally bounces it around
the scene and the light is influenced by
the surfaces it hits so if i was to take
the floor for example and just drag and
drop a new material on it like like red
for example you can now see there's red
light bouncing around the scene and if
you really just want to
crank it up to 11 i could drag and drop
like this neon green color that i
imported from the early 90s and you can
see that the sunlight hits that and
floods the whole scene with green light
now in addition to bounced light
lumen also allows us to illuminate our
scenes using emissive materials so
here's a ball that has an emissive
material on it and it is casting light
into the scene but it's hard to see with
all this sunlight so let's just take the
sun and tuck it up underneath the level
and now you can see that the ball
actually is casting light and there is
no light actor there this is all
happening by way of the material thanks
to lumen is a procedural mesh so if i
get it into the middle of the room
and then right click on it and go to
scripted actor actions i can swap this
out to its generated mesh and now we can
see a selection of handles that i can
move around and you see how that updates
the object so i can move the window
around inside the shape and if i go over
to the details panel i can increase the
wall's width
we could increase its height
uh we could actually adjust you know
what let's take the opening and we'll
change it to make this into like a
bunker that i can kind of hide behind to
we can increase their length
and we can increase their height
and the system just automatically
generates stairs for me so
we'll just connect those right up and
make a couple of quick edits there we go
that looks pretty good
hey everyone teddy here
high quality fodrill content is
incredibly expensive and time consuming
to create but now with the advent of
unreal engine 5 and nanite micro polygon
geometry it's finally possible to use
this movie quality content as is to
create real-time experiences that are
indistinguishable from reality
regardless of which industry you're in
with a simple drag and drop you can
instantly stream in for real nanai
content to build any world imaginable
and if you need even more assets and
can't find what you need in the mega
scans library or unreal engine
marketplace we've joined forces with
both artstation and sketchfab working to
make millions of additional marketplace
assets more accessible to developers
sometimes you might not find exactly the
assets you're looking for and would like
to create it yourself but take it from
me scanning custom assets has always
been incredibly hard work that requires
a great deal of training as well as
specialized and expensive hardware and
software
for this reason we've been working to
distill our scanning experience and
technology into an easy to use phone app
bringing the gold standard of
photogrammetry straight into your pocket
we're calling this app reality scan with
the next generation of unreal engine
launching we have been working on a new
community site def.epicgames.com
community the site brings together a
number of different community channels
and tools to make it easy to find all of
our resources in one place learning
content forums questions and answers and
code snippets it is awesome to see so
many inspiring projects from game
developers filmmakers and creators of
animated entertainment lifting up their
voices and vision through the power of
unreal engine
we are thrilled to confirm that all of
the amazing studios you see here are
part of the unreal engine 5 community so
at the end of this very exciting hour
let's recap unreal engine 5 is out and
available today in addition to the lyra
starter game an awesome project you can
use to build and ship your first ue5
game not to mention thousands of free
assets from the matrix awakens buildings
meta-humans vehicles everything you need
to get going building dynamic open
worlds
all of this is free to download and use
and be sure to check out the brand new
community hub for even more resources
and to help you get going and connect
with other developers
let's build the future together
[Music]